the Tokyo Olympic Games in July and
August could be postponed because of the
coronavirus japan's Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a has acknowledged the
possibility of pushing the event back
for the very first time saying a
decision could become inevitable ah they
have previously insisted the games would
go ahead as scheduled the International
Olympic Committee opened the door to a
postponement on Sunday when it said a
final decision would be made within the
next four weeks but it added that a
cancellation was not on the agenda
Canada and Australia say they will not
send teams to a July Games well our
correspondent mark meadows and d-double
sports is covering this story for us
good morning mark a postponement it's
looking increasingly likely isn't it yes
I would say it's almost certain now that
the games will be postponed
probably until July or August 2021 now
there are other options one of those is
cancellation but they've said they do
not want to cancel the Japanese of
events invested so much money in these
games already at the last count twelve
point six billion dollars and it's
probably gonna rise so I think
cancellation is completely out of the
question a scaled-down Games happening
this year with no spectators maybe less
sports it's possible but that's not
really what the Olympic Games is all
about and no one really wants that so I
think if we listen to Shinzo Abe aid the
Japanese Prime Minister talking in
Parliament today it's pretty clear that
postponement is most likely the IOC
decision is in line with what I've said
we want to hold the event in its
complete form if that becomes difficult
we will think of the athletes first and
foremost we may have no option but to
consider postponing the games so big
step they're actually moving for and
saying could be postponed what's behind
this change of tune from the Japanese
and basically pressure from athletes
it's become overwhelming it's hard to
find an athlete out there who basically
wants the games to take place this year
Canada have actually gone further
they've effectively boycotted a Games
this year they put
a statement saying it is not safe for
our athletes their families and the
broader Canadian community the
Australians have said something similar
they've said they've had to make the
call now for the good of their athletes
to say look you should start preparing
for 2021 because obviously the pandemic
has caused havoc with training regimes
people haven't been able to train we've
all said the problem with qualifiers for
the actual Tokyo games if they were
going to happen this year a lot of those
have been postponed so we don't actually
know which athletes would take part in
Tokyo so everything basically points to
a postponement how could the games be
salvaged successfully mark is there an
option for that I think so I mean the
Japanese were so happy when they won the
bid in 2013 and you know they were ready
with all the venues in double-quick time
those venues are still gonna be
relatively new they're still gonna be
there in July or August 2021 obviously
all the volunteers are there for this
year but they could quite easily be
persuaded to put it back a year or the
hotel space is there so it's easy to see
how a full Olympic Games could take
place in 2021 the problems he comes
if this pandemic is as serious as it is
now at the end of this year they might
then panic and think hang on
even July August 2021 is too close and
there's also a problem that the World
Athletics Championships is due to happen
in Oregon in August 2021 and also the
Swimming World Championships in Japan in
July 2021 there are those two a flagship
Olympic events there's no way they could
actually happen if the Olympics was
happening at the same time so there's
lots to work through and that's probably
why they need this four weeks to make a
final decision sporting world like
everything else in disarray mark Meadows
from DW sport thanks so much let's go
straight to Tokyo now and speak to
journalist Michael Penn he's the
president of the shin gets you news
agency hi there Michael Canada says it's
not going to send athletes to the
Olympics this year Australia has
suggested the same Shinzo Abe a has been
insisting the games would go ahead as
planned but isn't it inevitable now that
they'll either be cancelled or as our
BAE himself as hinted postponed yes you
put your finger on exactly the the
actions which both the Canada Olympic
committees and the Australian government
are taking effectively have collapsed
the the current line of the Japanese
government as well as the International
Olympic Committee you know they have
been trying to hold the line saying that
there would be no change that things
would go forward but while they kept
delaying and and you know essentially
being inflexible other people have now
taken this decision out of their hands
and I think that there will be many
other countries following Canada and
Australia in making the moves that they
are so the decision is no longer the
International Olympic Committee's or
students of Abhi's decision themselves I
want to talk to you a bit about the the
background behind all this it's been
nine years since the Fukushima disaster
how much is the desire to show off the
recovery in Japan from this disaster
playing into the reluctance to to
postpone or cancel the Olympics I would
put that factor a little bit lower than
some others I think that rather than
being a showcase for recovery it's more
of a showcase for Shinzo Abe A's regime
and what it's done since it's been in
power for over seven years you know he
was the one who launched the Olympic bid
and you know many people remember he
dressed up as Mario the video game
character at one of the at one of the
events so he's very much put his own
prestige on it aside from prestige we're
talking money for six or seven years you
know Japan has spent an enormous amount
of money to prepare for the Olympics and
not just the government businesses and
organizations we've you know all been
looking forward to 2020 and development
plans and timelines have all been based
on 2020 is the Olympic year and suddenly
that's being thrown thrown off and and
clearly it was very difficult for the
Japanese government to admit that its
long-held plans had fallen apart you say
people have been looking forward to the
games for such a long time now what do
people in Japan think about this today
want the Olympics to go ahead
public opinion polling is pretty clear
that the Japanese public is more
realistic about the issue than the
Japanese government has been the
Japanese public has been telling
pollsters that they they now think that
the games will be delayed or cancelled
and you know I think that most of them
are kind of just shrugging their
shoulders and saying well you know it's
just something that's out of our hands
it's in the hands of nature so you know
it we just have to go along with it
the Japanese government hasn't taken
that position yet but the Japanese
public has good to talk to you Michael
Penn from Nisshin gets you news agency
in Tokyo thank you